hey guys dr burke here in this video
we're going to talk about lemon water
and the importance of it i recommend it
for all my clients not necessarily just
for the vitamin c because it does have a
lot of vitamin c in fact two lemons a
day will give you all the vitamin c that
you need for the entire day
and just just as a side note vitamin c
what is it good for
bleeding gums if you brush your teeth
you get a little
redness on there that means you're
deficient in vitamin c it's a mild
version of scurvy
fatigue
that's one spider veins varicose veins
loss of collagen so you get loose skin
and by the way your adrenals hold a lot
of vitamin c
so that's the storage so it can make
more collagen so that's why adrenal
cases burnt out adrenals they have a
loss of collagen or protein
nosebleeds bruising but the most
important
thing to think about or or consider is
microhemging of the arteries what does
that mean it means that there's little
bleeding lesions that occur in your
blood vessels from a vitamin c
deficiency and what happens the
cholesterol and the calcium come in
there and plug it up as a band-aid and
that's what clogs arteries it's not the
cholesterol in the fat it's the micro
hemorrhage the damage in the artery
first
then the other ones come later okay and
even with an artery that has an aneurysm
that can turn into a stroke eventually
if it blows out
that's a vitamin c deficiency because
vitamin c strengthens the walls of the
capillaries and the arteries okay
so you can see the importance of vitamin
c you can get vitamin c from vegetables
citrus lemon lemon water
or else you can use
actual lemon juice i like to use an a
pure lemon like an organic blend
and like two to four tablespoons would
be one lemon okay and you put that in
your water have at least once a day
okay if you were to add
some apple cider vinegar in there
you could also create a nice little
drink and you could even add a little a
couple drops of stevia to make a nice
little lemonade okay now why why do we
need lemon
why do we need lemon water okay the most
important is it counteracts
kidney stones
now when you eat certain foods like
healthy foods like spinach kale
few lentils beans
nuts they're high in something called
oxalates okay
if you combine oxalates
with too much calcium so if you have too
much oxalate and too much calcium in the
kidney you could develop kidney stones
okay that's the most common source of
kidney stones and that can be very very
painful
so citrates from the lemon or lime
will dissolve
the stones or prevent the stones from
growing okay that is the biggest purpose
of lemon water it counters and protects
you against the kidney stones it
dissolves them and your body even makes
citrates but if it's deficient in that
you need to add it externally from the
lemons or the limes which are almost
identical as far as the citrates and
that way you can prevent stones and
continue to have
um foods high in oxalates like kale
cruciferous all the different uh
broccoli and things like that so that's
what i recommend
have your dr your water not just plain
but always add some lemon in it and you
can use it from a bottle as well you
don't have to have a real lemon
and go ahead and do this and and write
down your success stories below i'll see
in the next video